zu keiner phase gibt will wir haben sich
die fans auf ein fest wann die politik
auch das russische fernsehen hat
interesse an dieser gruppe zwei dutzend
fahrradfahrer aus der schweiz und
deutschland die meisten rentner auf
einer tour von moskau bis nach peking
ein ereignis das ich mir dass russland
korrespondent nicht entgehen lassen
möchte
in den letzten jahren musste ich oft
über einen russland berichten dass uns
vermehrt wieder aggressiv und
unverständlich erscheint
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diesmal stehen menschen im mittelpunkt
die sich über eine lange reise freuen
wir werden sie russland leben und vor
allem wie werden die russen auf diese
farbe gedruckt reagieren
mit diesen fragen mache auch ich mich
auf die reise in entlegene winkel des
riesenreiches
[Musik]
großes interesse hat offensichtlich auch
der russische staat die verabschiedung
wurde vom russischen tourismusverband
organisiert sogar der stellvertretende
leiterin macht seine aufwartung
[Applaus]
für uns ist es wichtig dass die
fahrradfahrt zufrieden glücklich und
gesund ankommen und dass sie auf der
ganzen strecke nur positive emotionen
haben und mit diesen emotionen heim in
die schweiz zurückkehren
das ist doch die beste form der volks
diplomatie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
war
ich wohne jetzt geht's los
jetzt geht's los
fast 8000 kilometer liegen vor
rentnertruppe die sie in 80 tagen
bewältigen wollen
mit dabei eine polizei-eskorte mich
interessiert wer dahintersteht
es sind doch einfache touristen eher
hatten das organisiert den auftrag haben
wir von der russischen regierung
erhalten jetzt sorgen für die sicherheit
dieser ausländischen bürger die fahrer
sind aber selber überrascht das ist der
[Applaus]
josef stand doch alles vitali der
aargauer neurentner ruhe die grüne mann
scheint uns von anfang an eine frohnatur
zu sein
darum wollen wir uns etwas näher an
seine fersen heften
vor zwei jahren war seine frau gestorben
statt der geplanten kreuzfahrt mit ihr
gibt es jetzt dieses abenteuer
das ist großartig diszipliniert fordern
eine verpflichtung selbst ausgebaut
aus sicherheitsgründen dürfen maximal
zehn fahrer zusammen unterwegs sein
mit hilfe eines russischen
geschäftsmannes hatte schweizer marcel
eisele ditto reale lang vorbereitet
unterwegs sind insgesamt 21 männer und
drei frauen
jeder von ihnen hat 20.000 euro dafür
bezahlt jetzt freuen sie sich auf
historische stätte fantastische
landschaft in sibirien der mongolei und
china sowie auf viele unvergessliche
begegnungen
[Musik]
wir selber werden bei weitem nicht die
ganze zeit dabei sein
unser nächster treffpunkt ist zwei
wochen und knapp 2000 kilometer nach dem
start im uralgebirge
ja selber so überrascht dass ich als
neues unbekanntes land
hahn erklärt oder mit nsu bestellt oder
kasan und ufer so super organisiert die
stadt mit modernsten architektur mit
öffentlichen gebäude und wieder wartet
straße alles spieler und freude und
glück und ich habe freude oder somit
kontakt mit einer weniger aber auch ist
bis jetzt aus positiv
das einzige echte problem für fast alle
die sich beschwert aber es ist nicht
wenig für den proportionen
wirst du recht
was sie mitnehmen das ist meine frau und
ich bin der klaus-peter im unterricht
kommen ausbleiben
ich bin jetzt 68 jahre alt ich hatte 33
jahre meine praxis in berlin hier bei
dieser reise jetzt viele haben mit sitz
probleme also probleme zu kämpfen
die schlimmste etappe war ja die erste
etappe raus aus moskau es geregnet hat
das war für viele probleme mit der
feuchtigkeit in der hose das reizt dann
noch mehr aber viele hatten am anfang
probleme und jetzt wird sogar ein
bisschen besser
ungeachtet der schmerzen setzten sich
die männer und frauen fast täglich aufs
rad
dieser wille und die verbissenheit
beeindrucken
die nächste station ist ein meilenstein
auf die rote die grenze zwischen europa
und asien
ich selber muss nicht in die pedale
treten und habe dafür zeit mich mit den
einheimischen zu unterhalten
zum beispiel mit rentner valerie der
ehemalige fabrikarbeiter lobt wie viele
auf der strecke seinen präsidenten
wladimir putin
eines muss man putin lassen er hat
russland wieder internationalen respekt
verschafft in den 90er jahren hatte uns
ja die ganze welt in die seele gespuckt
und wie geht es ihnen so wunderbar leute
mal die kamera aus dann erzählte
es ist ein täglicher überlebenskampf
eure rentner können sich solche
fahrradtouren leisten wie die hier nicht
wir haben kein geld dafür gerade mal 150
franken rente bekommt er die monat
menschen die von der wirtschaftskrise
betroffen sind aber die außenpolitik
ihres präsidenten loben treffe ich
häufig auf dieser tour
der nationalstolz entschädigt für die
folgen der wirtschaftskrise
bekommen haben als in europa
18 verschieben sich
übernachtet wird auf der tour
komfortabel in zwei bussen mit kalte
betten bordküche und werkstatt
[Musik]
ja ein bisschen kunst mit aufhalten
dank polizeischutz und diszipliniertem
farben sind alle heil unterwegs
[Musik]
sie fahren nach china wirklich
das damals
wahnsinn
sie haben halt wenig zeit zum leben sind
fast immer auf dem fahrrad
sie sehen aber irgendwie nicht aus wie
chinesen es sind schwarze ich dachte
schon etwas stimmt nicht
und wieso fahren keine frauen mit sie
kommen gleich die sind in einer anderen
gruppe
aber trotz sprachbarriere schlagen sich
die reise erfahrenen rentner bestens
durch
das ich
schließlich kommen auch und los
die medizin verbindet insekten im
bereich
diese art von freiheit sie weckt träume
auch bei küchen gehilfen addiert alex da
braucht man wohl viel geld um sich so
etwas leisten zu können
wenn ich die mittel dazu hätte so eine
reise in die schweiz wäre schon weiß
passt auf dass sie sich nicht entführen
wer entführt mich schon von hier aber
natürlich würde ich sofort mit mit den
rentnern naja soll gott sie beschützen
auf ihrem weg
die müssen aber eine gute gesundheit
haben
[Applaus]
und wie ist das leben für sie schlecht
geht es mir kaum arbeit kein geld und
immer dieser überlebenskampf mir bleibt
nur noch das obst und pilze verkaufen
und was haben sie davor gemacht ich war
verkäuferin und selbständige
unternehmerin
ich hatte ein gut florierendes
kleidergeschäft aber unsere regierung
macht die freien unternehmer kaputt die
steuern und die ständigen mieterhöhung
und waren nicht mehr tragbar
es macht keinen sinn es bleibt nichts
mehr übrig
[Musik]
tatsächlich ist die niedrige anteil der
kmu sun der russischen
wirtschaftsleistung ein grundproblem des
landes der staat ist die dominierende
wirtschaftskraft und weil putin und
seine entourage das zepter nicht aus der
hand geben wollen droht dem land
stagnation und rückschritt
wir treffen aber auch auf einen dem es
gut geht
die mit wie malen ist ein freund des
mitorganisators der tun und wie dieser
ein erfolgreicher geschäftsmann
beide gehören einem kriminellen
wirtschaftsverband an auf die mitglieds
parkplatz dürfen die fahrer übernachten
[Applaus]
die mit kraft noch auf das haus möglich
gemacht das ist ein wirtschaftsverband
von 200 jungunternehmer er ist einer
davon
herzlichen dank dass wir hier sein
dürfen und erfolgreicher unternehmer
haben in russland meist auch attraktive
mitarbeiterinnen
[Musik]
die meisten fahrzeuge hier sind
importmodelle seitdem hrubesch vor zwei
jahren sind sie teils fast doppelt so
teuer
dennoch laufe das geschäft gut sagen die
verantwortlichen
den hast du gekauft dafür nehme ich
jetzt dein fahrrad am nächsten tag jetzt
gleich wieder weiter
solche besuche sind selten nur kurz vor
landung kultur nur wenig zeit
wenn wir damit die macher dem es war
einfach die 18 tage verdoppeln wenn wir
über das schöne wort gehalten hat das
kulturelle und museale städte und dörfer
aller gemeinden könnten andere kontakt
mit der bevölkerung aber muss außerdem
berücksichtige die 8
da bedeutet und selbstbewusster und
priester jetzt kilometer vor
nach zwei wochen liegt der oral hinter
ihnen ein viertel der strecke ist
absolviert 6000 kilometer müssen sie
noch fahren
[Musik]
wir selber werden die truppe erst in
einem monat wieder treffen filmen tut
ein teilnehmer der gruppe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das nächste große ziel ist der baikalsee
die perle ostens für manchen im team ein
emotionaler moment
klick
es liegt also die augen greifen
wir freuen uns sie hier am baikalsee
begrüßen zu dürfen
dem team nächsten süßwassersee der welt
wenn es der russischen tradition möchten
wir sie zu brot und salz einladen und zu
muss deren saft alkoholfrei hier den
weiten osten russlands wieder ein
empfang für die fahrradfahrer aus dem
westen beeindruckend offensichtlich
werden keine mühen gescheut um die reise
zu einem erlebnis zu machen
[Musik]
homberg
und werden sie in der stille den abend
ausklingen lassen ist jede reise ein
großes thema im russischen fernsehen
[Musik]
die reise wird auf mehreren sendern
zelebriert
regelmäßig gibt es pressekonferenzen
eine wunderbare natur liebe menschen
restaurants auf europäischem niveau
das lob der gäste aus dem westen ist
balsam für die russische seele die
fahrradfahrer geben zu dass man in
europa ein verfälschtes bild von
russland hat hier können sie sich vom
gegenteil überzeugen und einmal mehr
stelle ich fest wenn der kreml will das
etwas klappt dann klappt es auch
[Musik]
danach verlässt die gruppe russland
nächstes ziel die mongolei auch dieses
teilstück bringen sie fast heil hinter
sich
[Musik]
und ich denke da gewöhnt und bordeaux
gewinnt und hochland und die steht nicht
mitgeboten sich suchen
[Musik]
nach 80 tagen stehen die fahrradfahrer
vor den toren pekings die reise durch
russland die mongolei und china geht zu
ende
[Musik]
eine solche tour mack risiken mit sich
bringen
aber dann schaue ich in die gelösten
gesichter nach knapp 8000 kilometern und
denke mir eigentlich würde ich gerne
selber mal mitfahren
[Musik]
genau